Speaker 1: Let's hear from a few more folks
in the audience for the first time in 2023.
We take calls via discord at David Pakman dot com
slash discord. You can join the waiting lobby if
you want to talk to me. You can raise your hand
almost like fifth grade all over again, which is
exciting. Let's go to Melody in Missouri. Melody
in Missouri, welcome to the program. What is on
your mind today? And thank you for being a website
member, by the way. I very much appreciate that.
All right. Melody may be gone. That's too bad. I
was looking forward to speaking with Melody. Let's
instead go to J.W.. You are from Atlanta, Georgia.
J.W. are welcome. I know you won't let us down.
Speaker 3: Oh, of course. I'm happy to. I'm.
I'm happy that you were at that You were able
to. We're happy to be here. I hope you're enjoying
your new year. Sorry if I seem distracted. I'm
just kind of watching all the chaos unfold
as they. As I'm. As McCarthy. As McCarthy.
I'm like, I think it was Einstein who said that to
define insanity is doing the same thing over and
over again and expecting a different result.
Speaker 1: And Republicans have certainly
been doing that this week.
Speaker 3: Yes. Okay. So
regardless of how this turns out, what do you
think will work, regardless of how this turns
out? What do you think is I guess I guess
House Democrats best chance of like using
the chaos that is inevitably going to unfold
in their in their in their in their favor when
it comes to the next election cycle.
Speaker 1: Here's my thought. Okay.
Republicans are going to try to obstruct Democrats
from getting anything done. And then in 2024,
they're going to say, don't vote for these
Democrats. They didn't get anything done.
The opportunity for Democrats here, given
that Democrats will control the Senate,
do not control the House, but it's very close in
the House is there should be situations where it's
either going to be some kind of spending bill
made up mostly of commonsense stuff that all
Americans want, or we might get a debt ceiling
situation or we are going to have things come
up in the next couple of years where Democrats
in the House and Senate are going to be united
with the American people in the Senate. That
will be one situation because Democrats control
it. Or you can talk over me. What's going on?
Speaker 2: Sorry?
Speaker 1: Are you talking
to someone else or to me.
Speaker 3: On the background noise?
Speaker 1: Oh, geez. Okay. So the point
I'm trying to make is Democrats
should have some opportunities
to really make Republicans look very stupid and
unnecessarily obstructionist in opposition to some
bills that the entire American public will mostly
be in favor of. Democrats have to just be prepared
to take advantage of those opportunities to be
able to fight back in 24 against the narrative
that Democrats got nothing done thanks to
Republicans, force Republicans to either
give you some wins or really make themselves
look like they don't have the interests of the
American people in mind. If they do get in the
way of every single thing Democrats try to do,
I think that's the one and only opportunity.
Speaker 3: Yes. And I would also like to add,
like, while not giving them any kind of like any
easier obvious wins that could that that could
that just as long as we don't do the thing where
it's where we somehow managed to snatch defeat
from the jaws of victory which is not.
Speaker 2: Completely which is not as
and which is not impossible.
Speaker 1: That's absolutely,
absolutely the case. J w r thank
you for the call. I appreciate it.
Speaker 3: Of course. Always happy to be here.
Speaker 1: J w r from Atlanta, Georgia. Wow.